this month is when the scary things
slinking around your house are not
ghosts or goblins but it's those
mysterious stains hiding in your carpet
but there's no need to worry because we
have Ben and Doug McKee here from
Zerorez our sponsors of this next
segment to tell us how we can turn our
homes back into a healthy safe Zone
welcome you guys good to see you
Mercedes good to see you now you have
this patented technology that I tell
everybody about when it comes to Zerorez
it's it's your patented ZR formula can
you tell everyone what that is and why
it makes such a big difference so the
biggest thing is the results you're
going to see in your carpets you're
going to notice there's no sticky
crunchy residue left under carpet yeah
it's going to dry extremely fast and
it's extremely healthy for you and your
kids and your pets that's what I love
there's no harsh chemicals nothing like
that it's just actual water that is able
to pull out these stains that we can't
even see correctly correct and our water
we've we've actually been laboratory
tested and we move up to 200 percent
more soil and contaminants of the
leading competitor which is unbelievable
people but the results be for themselves
you're going to notice a healthier
living environment you're going to
notice like we said it's not going to be
crunchy and it's just going to spell
fresh in your home or at your business
after we're done cleaning the
competitors try to be you but they
aren't you and we've seen the proof
before we show some of the amazing
results from zero res I want to talk to
you about something else that we've been
talking about doing air ducts how nasty
are our air ducts and you guys clean
them right we do so our whole approach
is we want to improve the indoor air
quality of your home or your business
and that includes cleaning your air
ducts there's a lot of contaminants and
dust and nasty things that can settle in
those duct Works we've even I've
personally pulled out a dead rat or
someone there doc so if you haven't had
them clean it's been a number of years
give us a call we are Professionals in
it we've got the latest and greatest
technology it's a negative air system
that we use it's safe and extremely
effective to get your Ducks cleaned up
this is why you are the most recommended
Carpet Cleaning company in the state we
love you guys let's take a look care
Doug show us a little bit about what
Zerorez does and talk us through this
Ben because this carpet is just pure
soil I don't know where you don't so
let's run we use we have a bunch of
these rugs lugging around our shop so
Vans are driving on them technicians are
walking on them and on it's like an auto
mechanic shop at our shop so it gets a
lot of dirt and Grime on it but right
away you can see the night and day
difference and my favorite part of
Mercedes
Dr Doug passes over it it's nearly dry I
I gotta film it's true like how does
that happen usually it would take hours
for it to dry yeah and what it is is
we've got our vacuum a really loud
vacuum hooked up to it's basically
hooked up to the truck's engine so it's
like having a 300 horsepower vacuum it
evacuates that water out of the carpet
we're not even getting the backing or
the pad wet it's just the carpet fibers
and that's the secret to a quick dry
time and that's why you guys are the
best you have an amazing special to tell
us about for our viewers today what's
that we do right now it's our
pre-holiday sale get three rooms of
carpet cleaning that's pre-treated
cleaned and zero resified for only 119
and we're gonna throw in a 300 square
feet of tile and grout cleaning
absolutely free minimum minimums applies
you gotta love that thank you so much
again thank you Zerorez for sponsoring
this segment take advantage of that
special three rooms of carpet clean for
only 119 plus free tile cleaning of a
hundred square feet call
702-840-3333 or go online at
zerorezlasvegas.com for more minimum
Supply
Las Vegas now we'll be right back